I was going to say part as a part of my
introduction that I am a very new
assistant professor so I still kind of
when I'm introducing myself have to
remind myself to say assistant professor
rather than PhD student uh but Michael
already did that so that's great uh so
today I'm really excited to talk to you
all about leveraging social theories to
enhance human interaction uh let me make
that a little bit more concrete to begin
with uh so I leverage theories about an
understanding of how people think
communicate and collaborate to design
effective and safe human AI
interaction I'll share more about this
as I answer three questions during this
talk what is an effective human AI
partnership how can we make human
interactions safe and what can we do to
enhance human inter action going forward
so let's start with the first question
there what is an effective human AI
partnership Effectiveness to me is about
combining people and AI in a way that
takes advantage of what they're each
good at so I'm going to give you a very
brief example of this for the setting of
visual question and asking um so not a
deep dive just a quick overview of what
I mean here so visual question asking
starts with a visually impaired user
sharing an image along with a query
online and trying to get an answer about
what's in that image so some examples of
this are what color is this or what item
is this because they can't see their
environment they're trying to get these
answers by asking them online now these
questions with these images are fairly
easy to answer especially with recent
advances in computer vision but things
can get tricky very quickly now visually
impaired users can't always see the
environment that they're taking a
picture in right so they can share
potentially sensitive content online so
for example someone someone might ask
which medication is this and instead of
just sharing the medication packet right
they can share a prescription bottle
with their name or their address on it
or someone can share a random image from
their Gallery with their face on it
right and and that leaks information
about them
online so what do we do here how do we
prevent visually impaired users from
sharing private content online but also
still be able to get answers to their
queries right one way to think about a
solution is can we opusc pre-process the
image in some way so it hides this
potentially sensitive content so for
example if this is your original image
can you op fiscated it to maintain the
context but not share what's private
right now this task is really hard for
people or AI to do on their own AI
doesn't always understand what we mean
when we say private or sensitive so they
can't automatically do this task and
people aren't a very reliable way of
doing it either um in both cases whether
you try to use people or AI individually
you have to share the original image
with them which sort of defeats the
purpose of the task itself so to solve
this problem in sort of a human AI
effective partnership way we divided an
image into segments and then we had
crowd workers look at one segment at
time so instead of seeing the full image
they just see a little segment now
people are really good at understanding
context that AI isn't so when I see a
nose in that segment I can sort of guess
that that's probably a face in the
surrounding segments and mark them guess
them as sensitive as well right and we
used AI for this task to optimize for a
certain budget that users provided and
also making real-time decisions around
which segments of these need to even be
shown again to different crowd workers
to make a decision about their
sensitivity so that's what I mean when I
say an effective human partnership we
started them with small segments and we
progressively had them label larger
segments that were already masked to get
to this image on the bottom left that
was then sent to third-party Q&A
websites to get answers to people
people's
queries I've done this sort of effective
Partnership of people in AI in different
types of domains uh visual Q&A workplace
settings U for data science and in all
of these the question that comes up next
for me personally is well what about
real world deployment right we're trying
to build these systems for research but
ultimately we want to put them in front
of actual users in the wild and that's
not quite as easy as just taking the
research system and then making it
available to everyone right there's a
lot of additional considerations that we
don't think of when we're building them
as research systems so for example for
the Q&A visual Q&A system that I just
talked about right you have to consider
Bad actors there might be crowd workers
that would work together on a sort of
forum and adversar attack the system to
get all of the image segments back from
it right so there's things that you
can't anticipate and now you might think
okay that's a hypothetical you know bad
thing that could happen but there is a
lot of evidence of how when human and AI
systems are deployed in the wild bad
things can happen biases that we haven't
considered or harms that we don't think
about can come up in these
settings so in my research this
Effectiveness is just one piece of it
there this whole conversation around
safety when you think about deploying
these systems in the real world and in
my research I try to bridge that Delta
between Innovation and effective
deployment in the real world by thinking
about safety and this includes two
questions about first understanding
what's wrong understanding the
incompatibilities that are at play that
cause harms and biases in the wild and
then also trying to address those
incompatibilities and that's what I'm
going to talk about next with sort of
how do we make humania interaction safe
but before I do that any questions so
far I'm happy to answer clarifying
questions as I go and then leave big
questions for the
end okay so l
I'm not the only person trying to study
how to make human interaction safe there
is a major thrust of research on
interpretability and explainability with
the idea being to help people understand
Ai and machine learning systems that are
deployed in the wild and the Assumption
there being you know if if we can help
people understand what these Ai and
complex Ai and machine learning systems
are doing then maybe we can stop
potential harms before they happen or
you know potential risks before they are
put in
systems there are two major approaches
to this uh there are glassbox models
that are inherently interpretable where
I'm very quickly able to tell how a set
of input features leads to a predicted
outcome and then there are blackbox
models where you can't really tell what
the machine learning model is doing but
the community has developed post Haw
explainers for these models that
approximate their behavior and so are
able to give you some idea of how a set
of input features leads to a predicted
outcome with these approaches you can
normally get three types of visual
outputs so say you were predicting
income based on demographic data you
could get a local explanation this tells
you how a single prediction was made so
on the y- AIS here are values of a
single individual and then you can see
how they shaped the final predicted
class of income here it's Z 0 just means
less than 50k income
you can also get specific feature
explanations which tell you how a single
feature affects the predicted outcome so
here you can see how age impacts income
across all data points in the data set
and then if you do this for all features
being used then you can get a global
ordering of what the model considers
important overall what it learns about
the data set and all of its features and
that's called a global
explanation so these explanations
provide insight into Model Behavior and
AI that we did not have
before but the question that remains is
does this work in practice do people who
use these systems then you know are able
to make better decisions about the data
and the model and that was one of the
questions that we wanted to tackle in
this project that we did uh this was one
of the first human evaluations of these
tools in practice uh which was done with
data scientists um data scientists
because you know they have some machine
learning expertise already they know the
machine learning Concepts we're talking
about here so we started with nuanced
sort of qualitative interviews to
understand the challenges that come up
in the data science pipeline we followed
this up with synthesizing these
challenges into a data set and then
running contextual inquiries to
understand if people were able to use
interpretability tools to resolve these
challenges and then we wanted to
quantify those findings so we conducted
a large scale survey toce those findings
from our contextual inquiry held up at a
large
scale unfortunately what we found was
that interpretability alone does not
work rather people misuse and overtrust
interpretability and explainability
tools so less than 4% of 197 data
scientists in our study could accurately
describe what these visual explanations
could do or what they were trying to
tell us right um most of them them
overestimated the capabilities of
interpretability tools so here you can
see on the Y AIS various different
capabilities of interpretability tools
and we had asked people to select all
that apply to the tool that they were
using in the
study of these capabilities only the
ones in these bonded boxes are actual
cap or were actual capabilities of these
tools at the time of the study and as
you can see people assigned a lot more
value in terms of capabilities to these
tools than was actually possible at the
time and some of these are things that
are realistically not going to be
possible for a long time like automated
detection of fairness issues no tool is
capable of automatically understanding
all fairness issues in a
system most data scientists gave our
erroneous model that we had shared with
them very high deployment scores so they
said or you could deploy this in a loan
application being used in the wild right
you could you could do this right now
with the data in the model that you have
now again like I said we had synthesized
some errors in the data right so as a
result one of the visuals that people
saw was this so what we had done was
impute 10% of the age values in the data
set with a mean age as a result around
that mean age of 38 39 you see a huge
spike in the relationship between Asian
income right so we had syn synthetically
introduced this error and several others
and we were hoping that after seeing
these visuals with these errors people
would say well this model is not ready
for deployment but most of them gave it
a score of on average five on a scale of
0 to S so they were they thought it was
ready they came up with narratives to
justify the spike right so one thing
that a lot of the um participants in our
study said well around 38 or 39 is when
you pay off all of your loans so you're
actually taking all of your income home
with you so this Spike makes sense right
uh so they came up with these narratives
to justify was what was being shown by
the tool rather than using it as a as an
evaluative device right um so
interpretability as currently designed
does not work the solution that is
intended to help make human ey systems
safe for deployment doesn't quite work
now naturally the next question that
comes to mind is why right what's going
on here and that was sort of the
question that we wanted to ask as well
and again we wanted to study this in a
you know we wanted to not just think of
interpretability as a technical solution
but think of what social human- centered
factors might be at
play so we hypothesized that the bounded
nature of human rationality was what was
going on over here so there's a
cognitive framework called bounded
rationality which essentially says that
cognition is expensive ensive so people
apply heuristics as shortcuts to make
their decision making easier our brain
has two systems system one and system
two system one is sort of an automatic
intuitive and unconscious thinking mode
it's fast but it can be error prone as a
result system two is a more slow
controlled analytical and deliberate
thinking mode um it's reliable but it
requires significantly more cognitive
effort and research in Psych ology and
cognitive science has found that people
rely far more on system one than system
two in their day-to-day
lives so to quickly make decisions
people apply heuristics for example
there's the availability heuristic where
they use immediate examples of something
that come to mind rather than taking in
the full picture and the things that
come to mind immediately are usually
based on frequent examples or recent
examples or Vivid examples in your
life Another Hero to that people apply
is imitate the majority heris stic where
they go with choices that are popular in
their socially proximal sort of
reference group so for example when
you're ordering food on door Dash how
many times do you look through all items
on the menu where is selecting you know
a popular dish from a
restaurant so we want to see what does
this look like for machine learning how
do you define bounded rationality for
machine learning now this is where I
have an example notebook that you're
welcome to go to and try out sort of
things on your own I'll I'll mention
visuals that are important from that
notebook here in a second but again
you're welcome to play with
that okay so that notebook will take you
to an example of using the Titanic
survival data set very important data
set that tries to predict based on
passenger info whether someone survived
the Titanic or not um so in the notebook
you'll see the data set the model and an
explanation tool called shap
and these are some sha visuals that you
can see in the notebook right here so
here's the global explanation this is
sort of The Ordering of features that
the model things globally across all
data points is important about t Titanic
survival here's the relationship between
the sex and
age and
survival and this on the bottom right is
one single data point so this is one
passengers information on the y- axis
here and you can see how each of those
information pieces made an impact
towards the final prediction of survival
for this passenger now I'm going to ask
you a question that data scientists
often have to think
about what would make this prediction go
from one which is this passenger
surviving to zero not surviving very
morbid example I know but uh we're going
to talk about how we can flip the
prediction for this bottom right
passenger from surviving to not
surviving I'll even give you some
options you could change the cabin value
from d35 to
e67 you could change the fair from $52
to
$10 you could change the age of the
passenger from 37 to
70 or you could change the sex from male
to female so which of these changes or
more than one do you think would flip
the prediction for this passenger on the
bottom right to not surviving they
currently survived but we're wanting
them to not survive so take a couple of
minutes who to throw answers at me I saw
someone already say three changing the
age from 37 to
70 feel free to discuss if you want and
and we can come back in a second here
rning you're running the
code this is a very important data
science problem I know so I want you to
really think about
it all right show of hands how many of
you think one is the
answer all right nobody for one how many
of you think changing the fair will flip
this
prediction maybe a couple here and there
how many of you think it's
three wow that's a majority um and how
many of you think it's
four a couple okay
all right so like I said we're making
this Passenger not survive the Titanic
um so unfortunately for a lot of you
only one and two are accurate um so one
is a little bit hard to reason about
unless you really care about the
schematics of the Titanic and have done
in-depth sort of deep dives into it
right I don't know what cabin is where
in the ship so it's hard to reason about
that right but it is accurate I did run
it two is a little bit easier to reason
about right if you reduce the fair this
passenger potentially is in a lower
class cabin right and lower class cabins
were hit first so you can reason about
that three is also very easy to reason
about you increase someone's age maybe
makes it harder for them to get to the
lifeboats again I said this example was
morbid so I'm not going to take any
responsibility for what I say here but
in this case for this passenger uh the
age does not matter because the
passenger class being first class was a
mediating factor and then four is
inaccurate because females survived the
Titanic more than males did so both
three and four are actually
inaccurate now this exercise that we
just did here this type of applying your
her istics right to solve a problem we
figured that data scientists do this all
the time and the data and machine
learning and AI use that they do on in
their jobs right so we wanted to see to
what extent do data scientists s you
know pick accurate answers or to what
extent do these heuristics and biases
come to play and they pick inaccurate
answers um so to make this entire
setting a little bit more formal we have
these axes to propose quadrants for
bounded rationality uh the axes are time
and cognitive effort because that's what
has been used in the past to study
bounded rationality and decision making
now when you apply deliberate reasoning
like for those of you who maybe open up
the schematic of the Titanic to figure
out where the cabin was right when you
deliberately think about something and
spend time on it it's called maximizing
your cognitive mode right and we felt
that in the interpretability setting
given everything we know about overuse
of interpretability tools this would be
the control condition without any
interpretability now again because of
what we know about interpretability
already we felt like the opposite where
you don't spend a lot of time and
cognitive effort in your decision making
making the satisficing cognitive mode um
would be where the visual explanations
that you just saw would land right so
these are the visual explanations static
visuals from interpretability tools
would fall under that
category now there's the cognitive mode
where you have to make very quick
decisions but these are also very
critical decisions so settings like
healthcare where you're really as a
doctor making decision about patient
survival so we call this The Sur surval
cognitive mode luckily data scientists
rarely operate in that quadrant right
they often have more time with the data
so this wasn't one of the conditions in
our study and then that's what I like to
call the optimizing cognitive mode where
you're spending a lot of time with a
system and interacting with it and
engaging with it but it's not
cognitively effortful you're enjoying
spending time with the system so one
thing we learn in HCI is to sort of have
that kind kind of interaction you can
make a system more interactive more fun
to use with different kinds of features
so we hypothesized that if there were
interpretability tools that weren't just
static visuals but had more interactive
features they would fall under that mode
and there are tools that do that so
here's an example of Google's wtif tool
so using Google's wi if tool you can bin
color Scatter Plots using sort of
different goorts of
data as you can see here um you can also
look at counterfactuals for a single
data point so you can kind of see what
the nearest counterfactual is you can
see partial dependence plots for the
feature relationship with the output uh
you can see how each individual
prediction was made what was important
towards that prediction change these
values in real time and get sort of real
time predictions with updated values for
data point so there's a lot more you can
do with this tool than sort of the
static visuals that we saw saw before
and this is just under the data point
editor there are other tabs for
performance and fairness metrics or you
know different types of feature
information that this interactive tool
allows now it isn't that the information
that forms the basis of the decision-
making that we did with the static tools
has completely changed the information
is the same the visuals that they're
using the three types are still
primarily the same it's just that
they've added interactive elements on
top so you can change things more
quickly get a reactive sort of feeling
with the
system so we ran a pre-registered
control experiment it was between
subjects it was with data scientists uh
about 119 of them where we tested their
performance between these conditions
that I just described we had a control
condition and two conditions each for
visual explanations the static outputs
and the interactive tools why two
because we we were testing a glass boox
model a glass boox approach and then a
post talk explainer for a blackbox
model the setup was very similar to the
collab notebook that I shared with you
all um they could access code they could
write code they could access any visuals
they wanted and in parallel there was a
qualtrix setup qualtrix is a server
platform um so they answered multiple
choice questions about the data and the
model on qualtric we had also provided
hints throughout the study because um
you know in running a study you have to
be careful about not making the task so
cumbersome that participants can't solve
it so that was the highle
setup any questions before I get into
even more
detail yes yeah the control um can you
just explain a little bit more of what
that actually looks like is just like
they're just going through like data
sheets or like what is that it's just we
give them a notebook with just the data
set loaded and machine learning model no
interpretability any other
questions yes for to know what tools
they have available like what's their
experience was their specific criteria
yeah so like I said it was just the data
and the model in a notebook so they
could write their own code on top we did
give them links to potential explanation
outputs but we did not give them the
Code in the other notebooks those
explanation outputs were sort of
embedded in the notebook by us already
the interpretability tools were already
embedded in the control condition if
they wanted those types of outputs then
they would have to go go to the links
that we had shared read the
documentation write their own code and
then get those
outputs but that's a good question that
leads into the results a little
bit all right so to study bounded
rationality to measure whether it was
happening right we had some proxies the
there were process level proxies that we
wanted to measure these were predictably
time and cognitive effort which have
been you know all about the axes that we
had designed to begin with we also
included the number of hints people used
during the study as a way of measuring
whether they were applying bounded
rationality and then of course does the
outcome right what happens as a result
of the application of bounded
rationality in the setting so these were
things like the accuracy of people's
answers about the data and the model
and then the types of answers they
selected so in the exercise we did you
know there were some options that were
purely accurate some that were plausible
that we could reason about but maybe
accurate or inaccurate and then there
were answers that were purely inaccurate
there was no plausible reason for them
to be accurate right so we had these
categories of options in our multiple
choice questions that we also studied as
part of the um quantitatively defining
bonded rationality so to study our
continuous variables we used one way
anovas and Tuki hsd as a post talk test
to study them
quantitatively um and then for our
categorical variable we used Ki squ test
of
Independence I'm going to mention three
of these in the results just in the
interest of
time so let's look at the time spent on
task now as you can see here people in
the control condition spent far more
time in the task significantly more than
any of the interpretability conditions
so just as a basic thing it seemed like
you know people in the interpretability
conditions spending less than 5 minutes
on task were clearly applying some way
to make the task go faster compared to a
control condition without any
interpretability somewhat and I should
have said it's five times more time
spent on task in the control condition
now maybe somewhat as a consequence of
that for accuracy control also had the
best numbers people in the control
condition
were at least 17% more accurate than
those in the interpretability conditions
um interpretability tools whether they
were static or
interactive did not seem to help yes
what's chance accuracy here chance yeah
like everyone's do most the conditions
are doing below 50% yeah um it was um we
had five conditions or five questions
five options each So
20%
okay and then of course if you look at
the residuals from our Kai squ test they
also showed the sort of significant
directionality of people in the control
condition picking accurate answers
compared to the other conditions which
leaned more towards um the other types
of
answers so overall our results from our
experiment uh just to sort of mention
them in the context of this quadrant
that we started with um we're pretty
expected for the satisficing conditions
the people who were using these static
visual tools were satisficing they were
spending less time less cognitive effort
what was surprising was the interactive
tools conditions we we had expected that
people would spend more time on task and
maybe get to more accurate answers using
these interactive tools but in practice
they sort of fell in the surviving
quadrant instead um and I'll exp I I'll
mention my hypothesis why right so for
the static tools we had thought these
make things look so easy in the form of
just these static visuals that people
end up applying their cognitive heris
stics instead for the interactive tools
it was the opposite they are so
complicated there's so many features so
many toggles so many interactive
elements right all coming at you at once
that people applied their own heris sixs
as a way of not doing this cognitively
burdensome task in instead our control
condition seems to be more closer to
optimally effortful than we had expected
and I think this is because of the
question you asked before where people
did want interpretable outputs right and
they would have had to read
documentation and write code to do it
and we provided them with just the right
amount of information on which code to
implement right we gave them the link to
the right thing that they could then use
to kind of Implement and have in their
notebook as an answer so that's why we
feel it was maybe closer to that
optimally effortful condition that we
were hoping interpretability would
be so that's sort of our hypothesis for
what's not working and why right the
bounded rationalities that play that
current interpretability tools don't
really take it into consideration don't
really account for the fact that people
apply curis stics and biases I want to
do another quick pause there if anyone
has any thoughts comments questions I
was in the control setting when if the
people did add interpretability tools
and which ones did they tend to so it
was different in that we did not want to
give them the same tool as the other
conditions because those were heavy duty
full sort of feature interpretability
tools that would have required a
significant amount of work on their part
instead we gave them links to codes
about similar explainers so if you
wanted to get feature attribut utions
like the global explanation here's an
equivalent that looks similar so sort of
similar but not the same tools yeah how
many approximate percentage of people
that were actually implemented those
tools because you had a very large
standard deviation yeah you're right the
standard deviation is pretty large and
that was sort of one of our concerns as
well so of the 22 people in that
condition I believe it was the number
was 14 who actually wrote code for the
tools that we had linked but in addition
to that the other participants still
wrote Cote it was just not implementing
what we had linked them to so all the
people in that condition wrote some kind
of
code would you expect the results to be
different if had or time constraint or
had enough time to work through these
to um so we did not assign have any time
constraint in the study the only time
constraint was that it was a study so
they were taking time out of their daily
practices to do the task um but what we
were surprised by was this inclination
to quickly find answers that
interpretability conditions were sort of
serving
right people people were using tool
about these tools so they knew how to
work with them or they had to learn or
you gave them a tutorial before using
the tool good question so we had people
with prior experience in machine
learning and interpretability in general
in the study not the specific tools but
we did give them a tutorial and
information about the tool before the
study before we started measuring the
time they were spending on things reason
I'm asking that is because I think these
people may have trust the tool or the
outputs because they don't know how it
actually works right so as far as we
know um well I guess we didn't really
get into since the conditions were
randomly assigned we didn't really ask
about specific tools that people had
used before but the only thing we sort
of know going in is that they had
machine learning experience and then we
gave all of them the same kind of basic
training on how to use the tool so
whatever inferences they made about that
training about the tool through that
training you know there's there's going
to be variance that's sort of covered in
the number of responses
yeah I don't know what order people were
asking questions in so I'm going to go
here sorry um I guess in a similar vein
how do you think these results would
change if it were for a more General
audience or people with less technical
expertise yeah you know that's it that's
a good question
and my expectation is the
interpretability results will be worse
because not everyone knows how to code
so in a control condition without any
interpretability being having to do that
coding task might not be feasible for
everyone right so people would over rely
even more so on the interpretability
outputs and that's sort of my worri is
that if people with machine learning
experience can always distinguish or use
these tools the right way then what can
we expect from you know lay and users
who don't even know how a model works or
what goes into the
process
yeah control condition whether they were
coming up with static visualizations or
like setting up an interactive tool that
would allow them explorative yeah so it
was mostly static visuals not
interactive but they were writing quote
for them yeah I thought that was one
more hand oh yes uh just a question
where even though the control they did
take more time they're also writing will
take more time I don't know how much
they sent like just observing their
their visual that they made I don't know
if you have those answers yeah but I'm
curious about your like I guess
hypothesis on like why they were a lot
higher just taking to account maybe they
spent the same time like looking at it
versus all that extra 20 minutes was
like writing this code was it something
that they they wrote out themselves that
wasn't shown was there like what was
going on there yeah so we weren't
observing the participants so I I don't
know what EX ly was going on but my
hypothesis is that when they had to
write the code to get to the visual they
paid more attention to the output than
if the visual was already provided by an
interpretability tool whether that's
interactive or static that's just my
hypothesis though
yeah yeah so just a quick question on
you know visualization literacy like did
you get any measure of you know I mean
it's it's it's counterintuitive that
data scientist visualization you know
like they'd be you know super at
interpreting visuals but did you measure
anything like that we have an exclusion
criteria around machine learning
experience and interpretability
experience where the question around
interpretability experience was around
visual explanations from
interpretability tools but we did not
measured beyond that mostly because um
you know there are some outputs from
these not particularly these tools but
in the control condition in particular
that are just static sort of number not
even visual outputs right so um we
weren't really trying to think too much
about the visual component it's just
that was the nature of the
state-of-the-art tool so we felt that if
anyone had used interpretability before
that was sort of if they were in the
state in state-of-the-art machine
learning interpretability pipeline they
had use the visual ones all of them yes
I'm curious about the axis of like
generalizability you want here like one
axis is that this generalizes to other
tools that you know Future tools even if
if they gave perfect explanations this
would still happen and you know accuracy
would be bad the other access of
generalization is to people like like
okay like the tools just are never going
to get there and you know people are
just going to be people I'm just curious
like ultimately is this a message of
like optimism toward like well these
tools can't do it but maybe future ones
could or like even if
given future interventions this is still
happen yeah
so I think bounded rationality as a
concept and as a theory that we know
about cognition has existed for a long
time right so that axis I think is
somewhat covered already by this
generalizable bounded rationality Theory
right our goal was more to sort of make
it more clear how that's affecting
machine learning and interpretability
pipelines for experts right um so if any
generalizability here that we cared
about was in the tool design like are
these types of tools tools that are
visual outputs of a certain kind maybe
made more interactive what can we do on
that axis of tool design of
visualizations um to account for the
fact that things will always be
boundedly rational so we wanted to the
type of generalizability we were trying
to tackle was on the tool AIS that you
mentioned the first one not the second
one because no matter what specific tool
you use used these are the three maybe
another couple more types of
explanations that you get from all of
them they might be presented in slightly
different ways but the kind of heart of
the information being presented is the
same as these tools and someone could
walk away from this study saying okay if
we're going to be boundedly rational
given the your results we should just
never use explainability techniques is
that like is that the right or the wrong
conclusion from this um I think it's
somewhere in the middle where at least
in the the paper about this we talk talk
about potential strategies right because
um you're right that maybe the easiest
solution is that we make people work
hard for getting interpretable outputs
but you can also do that with these
tools right the it's just that the scale
here was too easy with the visual
explanations or too hard with the
current interactive tools so maybe the
right answer is somewhere in the middle
right where we want there to be a level
of difficulty but we don't want it to be
as cognitively burdensome as sort of how
the interactive tools were
all
right all right let's let her continue
yeah there'll be there's a little bit
more here all right so the important
question right that some of you also
asked what do we do about this how do we
enhance human interaction going forward
knowing what we know about sort of the
results that I've
presented so this is where we were
looking for inspiration outside of
technical Fields entirely right we try
to see what human factors might be
relevant how do we re-envision
interpretability and explainability so
that these human factors are part of the
conversation from the
get-go and the theory that we looked at
was organizational Theory now you might
ask why organizations what do
organizations have to do with any of
this right um organizations form when
there's a need to collectively process
information at their heart there's sort
of systems of information exchange where
you work not only on your individual
task right but you also work in teams so
you have to understand the task together
as a team there's a lot of shared
meaning making happening and you work
across the organization and different
teams that all have the same goals so if
there's some way in which organizations
have managed to handle the intricacies
of human sense making and cognition and
still kind of be successful there might
be something there that we could learn
from and not just be successful there's
a subset of organizations that are all
about safety these organizations are
called higher liability organ
organizations uh or like healthcare Air
Traffic Control Systems naval aircraft
carriers nuclear power plants where
safety is critical right so they've done
they have metrics in place measures in
place and practices in place that
enhance the safety despite people being
people and doing people things right so
looking ahead I wanted to take
inspiration from these organizations so
this is sort of the set of projects that
I'm working on right now hopefully
students soon um I proposed this idea of
inefficient AI for safe human
interaction now let me start that off
with an example okay so imagine a naval
aircraft carrier if you ever read a
study on the flight deck on a naval
aircraft
carrier if you were prioritizing
efficiency you would have maybe one
person doing each job each job that's
required on the flight deck of En enal
aircraft carrier but if you look at what
actually happens on the flight deck deck
there's one person doing the task and
two people just sort of watching them do
the task for each task that needs to be
done there's a supervisor that looks
over the entire deck and there's two to
three people helping the supervisor so
there's a lot of redundancies and
inefficiencies that these higher
liability organizations add to their
pipeline because to them safety is
critical they can't afford to make a
mistake um so sort of you know going
with that idea for interaction here are
some design ideas I have so let's think
about seamful uh in HCI in particular we
talk a lot about seamlessness of
integrating our product into people's
everyday lives right and that's in this
setting for interpretability in
particular causing a sort of automated
response where people quickly make
decisions so how do we introduce the
right amount of complexity as we're
introducing these tools into their
pipeline
similarly can we induce skepticism in
people can we make them question things
instead of simply looking at information
or simply parsing
information and can we help them engage
in adversarial interactions so this the
idea behind adversarial interactions
comes from Red teaming right so you sort
of come together put different people
together on the same team with different
expertise to attack the system to make
sure that it's not going to fail so how
do we failure approve these systems
using these adversarial contestation
sort of
mechanisms um some ways in which we're
doing this for interpretability are
instead of seeing like a top end
important features visual make it a
conversation and all of you are probably
aware of large language models right now
which enable this sort of conversational
format right but what's the right type
of conversation is it a dialogue is it a
question asking setting like the
Socratic method using that with AI and
interpretability outputs right so
testing out these different types of
formats for conversation and instead of
you know again this is sort of uh making
things more seamful but you can also
make people a little bit more skeptical
by showing not just the top end
important features that the model did
consider in making a prediction but the
bottom end features that it did not
consider important right and maybe you
add random caution Flags to the
information that can be again randomly
generated or system generated in the
back end based on some anomaly detection
or other analyses that are already being
done by data scientists so again it's
all about presenting the information
directing attention the right way rather
than completely changing what we think
about interpretability from sort of
scratch you could also Imagine enabling
adversarial interactions by things like
slack right so you could put together
people from different teams with
different expertise say before a model
is deployed a model engineer a system
designer a frontend designer a back end
designer coming together to see these
outputs about a system all together
right so here's an example interaction
that might happen um you know this is
the same information as before someone's
asking more about it thinking more about
it now that they're in a group setting
kind of going off of each other's ideas
the system seamlessly adds more
information in the slack
interface leading to maybe an
information request from an individual
on wanting to explore something a little
bit more allowing that also to happen
here's a seamless example of allowing
that to happen in sort of the
conversation um recording context for
other people in the
conversation coming back to the main
setting and continuing sort of
conversation with different people so
how do you put different people all
together in the same setting to have a
conversation about the fail of
model now of course inefficiency can be
a potential solution here but just
making something inefficient is not
always right right you can't just sort
of make all interactions inefficient
when you're thinking about making
something seful you also have to balance
that with usability like the interactive
interpretability Tools in our in our
experimental condition were too
cognitively burdensome to use so they
weren't a good solution um as you make
people skeptical they still have to
trust the system right because there
needs to be some baseline trust um
otherwise they just won't use it and
then of course you want to prioritize
people thinking differently but you also
want them to have some
shared cognition about the task about
the team about the goals of the sort of
project at
large so that's my very quick overview
on how to use social theories to enhance
human interaction uh some of this work
was stuff that I did at Michigan has a
grad student but I'm really excited to
now continue doing it with undergrads
and grad students at Minnesota um and
sort of working with students who might
be interested on similar topics and I'm
happy to take any other
[Applause]
questions okay now you can
go yeah sorry this is pertaining to that
particular cscw study uh again between
the different groups I was just curious
if you had any guge as the like
confidence in sort of subjective
understanding of or confidence in their
own
interpretations and and their responses
that's a fantastic question so we did
measure confidence and other things like
how much of a novice they were within
the machine learning set setting in
general and what's surprising is that
people who were novices and had less
confidence performed better overall than
people who were experts and were more
confident about their answers so there's
something to be said about this idea of
inefficiencies both at the People level
and at the system level again yeah
thanks and then uh sort of kind of a
followup in terms of the interactive
condition um I you mentioned sort of one
of your hypotheses was that it was
potentially too uh overwhelming um did
you were you able to gauge any sort of
confidence dip to in relation into sort
of these interactive systems or I'm just
kind of reflecting and thinking when I
use a really complicated our first
encounter a complicated system maybe
within the time frame of a study I might
might not feel really confident but then
over time you know sort of learning and
and having time to sort of understand it
then potentially it could help improve
my accuracy yeah um that's another
really good point unfortunately for the
purpos of the study we weren't able to
see longitudinal sort of interaction
because it was a oneoff sort of task but
that's something that I'm interested in
more broadly is what kind of training do
you provide people sort of from the
get-go and as they sort of continue
using these tools and how that might
help mediate some of the effects that we
see here
yeah
yes curious like whether there there may
have also been you know people thinking
what you might be testing for example if
people think you're testing the how good
the system is then they don't
necessarily care as much about giving
you the wrong answers whereas the
control group that didn't have a system
they're interacting with it was almost
like their
reputation um i' think so like they
maybe actually tried harder to make sure
they the right answer instead of like
the other one yeah again good point and
maybe it could be I can't say for sure
that it wasn't but in terms of the
instructions that we gave people people
to counter that a little bit we told
them that the task was just to the study
was about performing an exploratory data
science task with the help of existing
tools so they didn't think that we had
developed these tools and we were asking
for their opinion about our
tools or I I mean that's the only way we
sort of even tried to mediate what
you're talking about yeah because we
didn't I did not
build these tools I've used them and
I've studied them and I've built on top
of them but the core tools were built by
organizations okay sorry so
popular please go based on your
knowledge of just um I guess other
studies with these tools I'm curious
about the context and and time people
spend like with the cognitive load so
like I like your visions of these things
happening in slack and maybe going
across an asynchronous conversation but
then when I think about the individual
spending five minutes like I think it's
your job you better not be spending five
minutes on it unless maybe you're like
an AI engineer it's like five minutes
before the meeting and maybe you know
prioritize that but I'm just curious
about your knowledge about that space
like what what what does it actually
look
like I think that's a really good
question and I'll tell you part of the
challenge in conducting research in the
space is that data scientists work in
organizations and their practices there
might look very different from sort of
what we study right we can try to create
an environment that looks very close to
how they're doing their daily work but I
mean even recruiting participants for
studies like these right if we're asking
data scientists to spend their time
doing this we can't possibly pay them
what they get paid in organizations
where they do this as their job so one
way in which we incentivized people to
treat this as an important task was to
say okay we're not paying you for for
this but we will donate a certain amount
of money to a charity of your choice
right because when people think of doing
sort of an altruistic motivated task
they do it a little bit more seriously
but I don't know to what extent this
would map to a person's day when when
someone treats this as their daily job
and sort of has their whether or not
they get fired attached to uh the way
they perform the task so that's sort of
going to be a a control issue that's
always going to be the case with with
research
yeah
complexations and founded rationality
aspects the nice thing is that bounded
rationality has been studied in many
many settings maybe in this setting it
hasn't been studied in a in a realistic
organization right because we're just
starting out to do this but in other
settings it has been studied in
organizations so I have some hope and
confidence that it might still apply
even in this setting and we're just
trying to answer the question of well
how will it apply and what will what
will help it rather than you know seeing
it again in a realistic setting like
that maybe one last question yeah so
this is also related to a little bit to
the motivation part because uh I'm C
because based on the setting it seems
like okay the human whether it's an
expert or not could do something the AI
or the model either X AI or the AI s it
could do something um there's a huge
issue of their incompatibility between
the two two of them right and so I I
would like to ask if you can say this
few words of saying that okay given I am
a human worker I'm working on something
what can I learn from the AI for
instance I'm using this AI it sounds
like it's going to make me lazy and and
my performance get way go go way low so
I don't want to use it right it's
something similar to The Scientist right
because if the scientist is going to be
like okay given this AI given this expan
AI it's going to make me work faster and
it's going to make me some some kind of
performance F I'm going to get a huge
pay salary right some I'm I'm curious to
say like can you say a few words of like
what kind of human workers SC from the
system MH yeah I I would I mean again a
great question and to some extent we
forget the time before this right so
that that was a long time in machine
learning and I when you couldn't see
inside the black box at all you couldn't
get interpretable outputs at all right
so our control condition tried to model
that but even that wasn't necessarily A
purely controlled condition in that we
still had helpful links for people to go
get similar visuals right so sort of
going back to when we had no help from
explainable AI it was a far more
challenging task because there was just
no information or very little
information so in some sense there is a
benefit right that explainable AI is
providing that we can at least now look
inside the blackbox and understand
what's going on but to your point about
us becoming
lazy having that that's where I I
personally think this idea of
introducing in efficiencies or
inefficient interactions might be
helpful and that we don't need to change
the information we now have which is a
good thing but maybe we need to change
how it's presented and how people have
access to it and what kind of attention
they're paying to it
I don't know if that answers your
question but just my thoughts on this
yeah it's very hard to say given it's
very hard to convince some kind of real
user to say okay this isem really
awesome I'm going to use it yeah maybe
you don't PCT it as really awesome all
the time
yeah all right let's thank our speaker
thank
[Applause]
you